[Musique]
je m'assois souvent sur un bon seul
comme ça pour me souvenir pour me
souvenir que suite à une agression
j'ai complètement oublié mes trente
premières années de vie et je les ai
jamais retrouvé et qu'à ce moment là je
disparaît mystérieusement
il ya de ça 32 ans pour me souvenir que
quelques jours plus tard et à 400 km de
celui d'agression un inconnu se réveille
seul sur un banc et que cet inconnu
c'était moi et devant moi je vois
l'opéra et je sais pertinemment que
c'est l'opéra et je sais donc que je
suis à paris c'est une évidence mais
presque instantanément
je prends conscience que je ne sais plus
qui je suis je suis un corps sans
mémoire et comme pétrifiés j'arrive pas
à quitter cet endroit je reste là et la
police ne tarde pas à faire un contrôle
d'identité
mais je ne sais pas qui je suis aucun
papier sur moi rien dans leur dossier
pour me protéger pour protéger les
autres me voilà interné d'office dans un
hôpital psychiatrique où l'art
immédiatement cachetonner je me retrouve
complètement impuissant pendant
plusieurs mois au milieu de gens que je
perçois comme étant des faux mais est-ce
que moi même je suis fou mais on
m'appelle monsieur x parce qu'on ne sait
pas qui je suis et là entre deux crises
d angoisse
je passe mon temps à écrire et à
dessiner dans l'espoir de faire
ressurgir quelque chose de cette mémoire
au dormi mais rien est un professeur
vient enfin me voir pour me dire qu'ils
s'occupent de moi depuis longtemps sans
que je le sache et que d'après lui
j'aurais fait des études supérieures
peut-être même une formation artistique
et à l'écouté de mon accent que je
viendrais peut-être de l'est de la
france
il me dit que je souffre d'une amnésie
identitaire et il me rassure en me
disant que ce n'est que passager
alors je reprends espoir je vous dis que
ce cauchemar va certainement se terminer
et rien ne se passe
j'attends encore et un jour on vient le
chercher dans pour aller dans un petit
bureau parce que l' enquête de police a
avancé il avait donné tous ces indices à
la police est on arrivé dans son bureau
je vois un professeur tout souriant il
me dit c'est bon vous êtes retrouvé vous
appeler jacques michel jacques michel
duret ces gens qui sont ainsi la sont
vos parents et votre femme martin o
il se présente à moi il m'annonce que
j'ai je suis même père de deux enfants
travaillent bilan et puis il me montre
plein de photos de mon passé mais ces
gens et ces photos ne me disent rien mon
coeur reste froid et après leur départ
le professeur me dis qu'il s'est passé
122 jours depuis la disparition et que
tous ces gens me croyais même mort et
ils sont heureux de me retrouver en vie
et que très bientôt ils vont dire me
rechercher et que c'est avec eux que
j'aurais certainement un déclic
communément appelé le déclic des petites
madeleines comme l'a si bien écrit
proust un bruce une odeur et claque je
serai de nouveau celui que j'étais avant
avec ma mémoire et la l'hôpital tout le
monde s'amuse à m'appeler jacques michel
jacques michel
mais ce nouvel inconnu qui est moi dans
mon corps me fait peur commence à
accepter sans se connaître
comment pouvoir rebondir sans passé sans
référence comment et la porte de
l'hôpital se referme sur moi pour me
laisser partir avec ces étrangers et là
je ne reconnaît même pas ma propre
maison
la seule chose que je suis capable de
demander c'est où est ma place pour
écrire pour dessiner ou et martin petit
femme devient ma nouvelle infirmière
c'est bien la première fois que j'aimais
le jacques michel que je ne connaissais
pas il avait bon goût elle était bonne
la petite brunette carrière sympa et le
lendemain mes parents nous ramène nos
deux enfants que je trouve mignon certes
mais encore une fois mon coeur reste
froid et les jours suivants on me
présente en vrai tous ces gens que l'on
m'avait montré sur ces photos
tous avec leurs conseils tous avec leurs
remèdes voire même avec des reproches
mais ces gens pour moi ne reste que des
photos vivante et je passe mes journées
à écrire et à dessiner s'en occuper de
ses proches et je me sens rapidement
inutile alors comment rebondir dans une
vie où je n'existe pas comment on va
tous ces tableaux qui commencent à
s'amonceler et qui devait me parlent et
qu'ils devaient dire quelque chose me
réveillais ma mémoire me disent rien
alors pourquoi les garder pour moi
les exposés et les vendre c'est ma
solution ça me permet d'exister de ne
pas dépendre et je vais au bout de cette
idée et je cherche un lieu pour les
exposer et une banque pas très loin de
chez nous accepte que je le fasse dans
leur pool et n'en font ils me font même
de la publicité des grandes affiches
également et montfrin vernissage hélas
les tableaux se vendent et il ya des
journalistes qui viennent même faire des
articles sur moi ma peinture est appelé
le sentimentalisme et dans les articles
j'ai dévoilé au grand jour
mon problème d'amnésie j'existe j'ai
vaincu ma transparence et là je retourne
à la maison et jour et nuit
je peins et je multiplie les expositions
pour exister mais je n'arrive pas à
oublier celui que j'ai oublié mes
tableaux ne sont que le reflet de mon
manque hélas je plonge dans une
dépression et là il me faut de nouveau
rebondir il le faut alors j'ai l'idée
d'ouvrir un atelier de peinture pour
adultes et pour enfants et ma petite
notoriété que j'ai eue grâce aux
articles dans les journaux me permettent
de convaincre la mairie de mon village
et ils me prêtent une salle aménagée me
paye même des flyers qui sont distribués
et les inscriptions augmentent 28 30
je viens de créer l'association des
adeptes du sentimentalisme
le mec il y croit il veut se montrer il
veut exister mais non contente ça me
considère en moi même comme étant un non
voyant de mémoire
je vais jusqu'à inventer un système de
peinture pour aveugles je me rapproche
d'institutions un autre monde ateliers
en envoyant et avec mon procès dès que
j'ai appelé la peinture tactiles ont
fait une première exposition une grande
exposition nancy et là d'autres articles
dans les journaux même deux télévisions
rien ne peut m'arrêter dans ma quête de
reconstruction
quoique sans m'en rendre compte
trois années viennent de s'écouler juste
occupé à athis et mon fils d'ariane et
sans m'occuper de mes proches
et là j'en ai là c'est plus d'un et je
me suis retrouvé de plus en plus seul et
martin sont bien perçus et c'est pour ça
qu'un soir martine me demande de
m'asseoir à côté d'elle elle me dit tu
sais mon chéri je suis tellement heureux
de voir revivre de te voir s'occuper des
autres
je préfère même celui qui est venu que
celui le petit fêtards que tu étais
avant mais ce fil d'ariane que tu
essaies tout de tisser seul dans ton
coin
j'aimerais bien qu'on essaie de tisser
ensemble et là sans vous dire comment
alors peut-être par pudeur ou alors par
amnésie ce qui serait le 20 la bonne
occasion quelques mois plus tard le
ventre de martin s'est mis s'arrondir ce
qui tendrait à prouver que j'étais pas
amnésiques de partout non plus un ace
qui prouve que le cerveau de l'homme il
n'a pas qu'un cerveau y en a deux en
avait un qui était intact et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai eu un déclic voire
peut-être une même une renaissance parce
que martin est vraiment devenue ma femme
l'enfant qui grandit c'est dans son
ventre était déjà le mien c'est une
évidence
j'ai enfin pris mes deux enfants dans
mes bras mais je les ai adopté dans mon
coeur et j'ai accepté le reste de cette
famille mes amis comme étant bien et
ces trois années la marque et
malheureusement aussi une autre séance
celle de main de mes droits en longue
maladie et je me retrouve convoquée par
un médecin conseille et vous allez voir
cela il est pas mal non plus il me
reçoit une vie bonjour monsieur rhéaume
monsieur x comme vous l'entendrez je
vois dans votre dossier que vous avez
exposé et vendu des tableaux créer une
association d'y donner des cours que
vous affichez dans les médias mais vous
écoute m'en fous on vous a donné ici
trois ans pour vous soigner et non pas
pour travailler au noir
alors vous n'aurez pas droit au statut
d'adulte handicapé
non vous allez retrouver un travail
allez vous inscrire à l'anpe pour moi de
toute manière vous prétendez même
inventeur mais j'ai l'impression que
votre première invention était celle
d'être amnésique
alors continuez à pain continue à
dessiner pour moi de toute manière vous
n'est plus malade le dossier est clos
je suis plus malade tu pu pousser
de gueule voilà d'après le pingouin je
serais plutôt fou de ne pas vouloir être
fou c'est fou mais quoi faire eh ben
c'est encore ma petite martine gemmell
des et je me rase retient elle me dit tu
sais mon chéri tu étais architecte avant
on te demande de reprendre ton métier ça
va être génial tu va réapprendre plein
de trucs et aura toujours le temps à
côté pour s'occuper de nous puis de
l'association
je m'étais même pas posée - la bonne
question à savoir ce que je faisais
avant
la seule chose qui m'importait c'était
qui j'étais qui n'avaient rien à voir et
la peur de me perdre de nouveau fait pas
confiance en moi
d'ailleurs j'avais tellement peu
confiance on voit pas peur de me perdre
mais tec 10 euros d'essence dans ma
voiture et je prenais toujours le même
chemin et par peur de moi je vous ai
même pas me regarder dans un miroir
je t'ai entendu tout cela non je n'étais
pas à cause de mon physique là j'étais à
l'époque aussi beau que celui que je
suis maintenant non mais quand je vends
des mois je suis content mais l écoute
du marchix j'ai eu deux un nouveau
déclic et je suis devenu architecte en
un instant ma tête c'est rempli de plans
de termes techniques
allez le professeur me l'avait dit je
souffre d'une amnésie identitaire mais
fort heureusement j'avais conservé
l'ensemble ou presque de mes acquis ce
qui est drôle c'est que je sais que je
sais mais sans savoir comment je le sais
et là je deviens pratiquement en même
temps perdre un troisième enfant
architecte et demandeurs d'emploi quand
même pas mal pour un mec qui était rien
quoi et une offre mais fait dans un
petit bureau d'architecturé
quelques mois plus tard mais voilà pas
côté de chez nous en bois non ces votes
et rosa non en suisse à 300 km de là
alors quoi faire et bien aller vers
l'inconnu
pour une fois qu'on amnésie on n'était
pas la cause c'était chouette quoi et
faire de toute manière ce que nous
faisons tous un moment donné où l'autre
de notre vie aline vers l'inconnu et là
je suis resté plus de quatre en suisse
où je suis devenu un architecte réputé
dans les bâtiments historiques jeu
redonnait vie aux anciennes pierres
comme si je faisais un devoir de mémoire
heureux en suisse la semaine heureux le
week-end est en vacances avec les miens
c'était une magnifique mais paf le chien
brutalement une rupture d'anévrisme
vient tuer mon père je viens de perdre
une racine avant même que l'on ait eu le
temps de nous reconnaître
et c'est à ce moment là que j'ai pris
conscience de l'importance des miens
j'ai pris conscience que la vie est
courte et qu'il était temps pour moi de
vivre avec les miens d'accepter celui
que j'étais en faisant le deuil de celui
que j'étais alors effectivement il n'y a
pas eu de déclic depuis de madeleine n'y
a pas eu
j'en ai bouffé j'en ai grossi d'accord
mais pas de déclic et je resterai je
suis encore aujourd'hui handicapé par
mon manque de passer mais je sais
quelque part que d'autres que moi se
sentent handicapés d'en avoir un si
cette étrange alors adieu la suisse
elle restera dans mon nouveau passé et
maintenant il fallait que je redevienne
une racine pour les miens et j'ai donc
retrouvé un travail pas très loin de
chez nous et enfin je suis venu comme un
homme normal j'ai vécu avec ma famille
avec mes proches mes enfants ont enfin
grandi avec un père à leurs côtés
et quand la mort est venue de nouveaux
mara chez des proches
je n'ai jamais pu enterrer d'étrangers
parce que j'avais pris le temps de les
connaître avant leur départ et la vie
nous a donné la joie de devenir grands
parents voilà et notre histoire va faire
l'objet d'un long métrage d'un film qui
en cours actuellement et dans lequel je
vais avoir un rôle ou de nomi lequel
celui de mon propre agresseurs et en
parlant de mon agresseur il avait été
retrouvé quelques années après les faits
il m'avait simplement volé ma voiture et
pour ça il m'avait assommé certainement
un peu fort parce que sans le vouloir il
m'avait aussi volé ma vie mais il avait
aussi donné naissance à ce mec
complètement hagard qu'on a retrouvé
seul sur un banc à 400 km de chez lui
sans savoir comment le déplacement s'est
fait mais il a également donné naissance
à celui qui est là ce soir devant vous
pour vous parler de rebond
celui qui va maintenant toujours en
compagnie de ma petite femme martine la
petite brunette de tout à l'heure qui
est bonne elle a d'ailleurs toujours
l'enquêté drees et on va ensemble vers
des gens qui se sentent perdus sur leur
chemin de reconstruction pour les aider
à avancer les aider à comprendre et à
bondir donc voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire ce soir c'est que pour moi rebondir
voyez ce n'est pas forcément réussir
mais pour moi rebondir
c'est vivre et ça même si jamais il faut
dire jamais je pense que jamais je ne
l'oublierai alors je me sens vachement
bien d'ailleurs avec vous ce soir c'est
vous est superbe
alors je vais me permettre de prendre
encore une petite heure si vous
permettez pouvoir conter l'histoire d'un
mec qui se réveille un jour sur un banc
à paris sans mémoire
face à l'opéra oui quoi
cette histoire c'est vrai excuse moi
mais c'est embêtant d'inviter un
amnésique à tmx
je vous souhaite une bonne ville
[Applaudissements]